what's up everyone we are currently in
Spoleto in italia we are in the Apennine
mountains this is the Spoleto valley
behind us this is a beautiful part of
central Italy and it is this has roots
dating back thousands and thousands of
years
and a lot of the structures are
thousands of years old and the history
and the culture is super beautiful and
relaxed and intellectually stimulating
and it's a beautiful place full at the
west and I would love to take this time
to talk a little bit about the
importance in nuance and gray area and
conversation the multi variability in
different points and calculating them so
if you've ever taken a debate class in
the past you would know that it's super
important to know both the pros of an
argument and the cons of an argument and
so this is something that were regularly
taught in our studies so the idea is
well why would if I stand let's say a
pro on abortion why would I learn the
cons of abortion why would I learn the
pros of war and the cons of war the the
pros of gun control the cons of gun
control
why would I learn all these different
perspectives on certain issues well it
actually makes you a better steel manner
you know how to rather than strawman
someone's argument where you take the
worst possible construction of their
argument one that they didn't even
really say but rather you fortify their
argument and you say okay even though
you are pro-abortion this is how I take
your perspective and I fortified I make
it really strong and then I maybe
counter it I maybe amplify further and
say that it's good in this way or bad in
this way etc so it's this general idea
of being able to take an argument that
is let's say pro health care for all
Universal care and make it either even
better or or counter it and make it take
the best form of it encounter it and so
that's the idea that's the really
importance of nuance
and conversation you know all these
different variables you know all these
different positions that people take and
then you're able to either break them
down or or after you steal man them or
amplify them further so that's the
importance of knowing all these
different positions in conversation and
that's why it's so important to really
be very careful with the way that you
converse with people and understand
nuanced a very the Kawana mmus when
conversing with people because we are we
are living in an age where people get
very agitated and and very they're very
attached to their ideas and but that
doesn't really help when it comes to the
really the thought-provoking testing of
ideas over time someone's gonna come and
test your idea very peacefully it's
important for you to also stay peaceful
and be very flexible flexibility
tranquille
these two words flexibility and calm and
so as you are flexible and calm with the
way that you see the world and you
perceive it you can then change the way
that you think about and learn about
differences in thought patterns and why
people think the way they do okay so
remember have both the pros mapped out
half the cons mapped out have all the
gray area mapped out calculate all of
the variables and all the positions that
people can take on these complex issues
and it will make you a much better
conversationalist debater enthusiasts
across all perspectives will make you
much better at making friends as well
and building rapport across different
perspectives so welcome to Spoleto and
italia in the central Eponine mountains
and welcome to this beautiful place of
history and culture welcome to having
nuanced thought-provoking conversation
remember why do you do what you do and
why is that important every single
moment of time why am i doing what I'm
doing can I be doing something that's
more meaningful more fulfilling to me
into my life and how do I find that
thing and pursue it and how do I find
more nuance and conversation much love
everyone thanks for watching from
Spoleto and eat valley
Oh mwah bellissimo